it looks like the new congressional
budget bill is not going to include any
funding I don't mean any funding for
Trump's much-talked-about Mexican border
wall now here's the weird thing you'd
think that would be disappointing for a
president Trump you know he made the
border wall one of his biggest campaign
promises but now some Republicans are
insisting if the wall is not built
that's okay because the wall was always
just a metaphor that's I'm not making
that up they're saying that it was a
metaphor I wanted to find out what they
meant by a metaphor so joining me now
via satellite I hope this works from the
Department of Homeland Security Tom
Ellingham Tom can you hear me
[Applause]
yes sir
find you there yeah yes hello Conan
thanks for having me well I'll get
straight to the point isn't suddenly
calling the border wall a metaphor just
a way to spin a failure into a success
absolutely not
when the president discussed building a
wall shouting this statement over and
over again in every town across America
he never specifically mentioned building
materials now he meant it as a metaphor
just like when he said Mexico would pay
for it
Mexico was a metaphor for American
taxpayers our president loves metaphor
so I'm sorry if it's not a brick and
mortar wall what would it even look like
that's a fair question
see the great thing about metaphors is
they can be anything the wall can be
several Border Patrol dog stacked on top
of each other that's not gonna happen
they're not gonna cooperate it could
also be a mere suggestion of a wall
we've discussed positioning well-trained
mimes along the border all pretending to
be trapped behind an invisible wall okay
no no yet you'd have to have thousands
of miles of mimes along the border how
would you feed them or even keep them
alive who cares they're mine okay but a
wall could even be a strong statement
like this here's a small sign that says
well how will that deter illegal border
crossings word of mouth now come on
my point is a wall could be anything a
bit of fence a loud siren a stern look
from a deli manager a kiss from add of
an emotional wall you put between
yourself and your friends to protect
your feelings stop it stop it no none of
those things are gonna keep people from
crossing the border I'm not even
convinced that all brick wall would help
what if the wall Conan we're a song now
forgotten I'm oh whoa I'm a wall and I'm
almost 30 feet tall if you're Mexican
then you can't come in I'm a wall what a
wall Oh
maybe Hemis right there you guys
you